[Music]
my name's Katie and my business is
Harbor and Tide this is Union yoga
studio and cafe and there's a fantastic
yoga studio with a full range of classes
and a plant-based Cafe
and me I opened on the 1st of November
and I'll be here till Christmas
when I founded the business it was it
was inspired by sea swimming something
that I started doing in 2020 like a lot
of people and the ethos really behind
the brand is joyful functional and
sustainable you know I really wanted to
show that you can make sell products
that are really attractive really
enjoyable to use really sort of colorful
and joyful but also good for the planet
I don't really sell anything that's
purely decorative so you've got hats and
gloves and scarves you know things that
you need really nice jackets for after
swim or dog walking made from recycled
plastic bottles things that people are
going to use
you know every day and get joy out of
while they're using it rather than just
sort of put it on a shelf and forget
about it
[Music]
I think a lot of people are really
trying to shop small and Shop local this
year I think there's an awareness that
the small businesses need that support a
lot more than the big companies do and I
do think that people could come into the
center of Ramsgate now
and do most of their Christmas shopping
I'm in a brilliant part of town we can
see the sea in the harbor from here
sunshines in through the window it's
great
foreign
business Community here and in fact
it's the people of Ramsgate with ideas
that are making Ramsgate better it was
really heartwarming that when I sort of
I was walking past Union where I am now
and just the idea struck me and so
coming in chatting to Amy her being so
positive about it knowing that we'd be
sort of supporting each other helping
each other in a difficult time you know
boosting each other's businesses
that I find that really inspiring
foreign
[Music]